In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 21st, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr
Julien of Celicia.
On the 21st of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Julien of Celicia.
A native of Anzarbus in Celicia, Secunda, now Agasli, St. Julien was the son of a pagan
senator, but had received a solid Christian education from his devout mother, Asclipiolora,
and was greatly learned in the inspired scriptures.
During Diocletian's persecution, he was denounced to the cruel governor, Marcian, who was
inflavious, and when he refused to sacrifice to idols, the governor had him flogged and threatened
him with terrible tortures.
The saint replied, I am not afraid of the torments, and nothing will make me deny the
law that was given me in my childhood, even if you burn me in the fire of these torments.
For I have Christ who strengthens me, and it is to him that I unceasingly offer a sacrifice
of praise.
The perverse magistrate forced him to swallow food, sacrificed to idols, but the saint replied
that whatever is done under duress cannot be counted as a sacrifice.
After having had him flogged again, Marcian took him to Anzarbus, the soldiers beating
him the whole way.
Arriving in the town, the valiant martyr appeared before the tribunal, where he showed the
same resolution, despite the wine offered in impious oblation that they forced him to drink,
and the incense that they put in his hands.
He was then transferred to a guy on the Gulf of Issykos, famed for its temple of Asculepios,
and was ordered to submit to the emperor's orders on pain of being consigned to the flames.
Julian replied to the governor, and what is stopping you doing that?
They then summoned his mother, who had followed him, hoping that her entreaties would move him.
Asculepiodora obtained permission to spend three days with her son in his prison, but instead
of exhorting him to save his life, she encouraged him to remain firm to death in the confession
of his faith in Christ, the conqueror of death.
And she particularly said to him, you know what is of real benefit to you, because I taught
it to you, act then to give glory to the one true God.
The time allowed having passed Marcian realizing that he had been tricked, ordered that Julian
be put in a sack filled with sand, and that snakes, scorpions, and all sorts of venomous
animals be put in it with him, and that he be cast into the sea.
Although the valiant martyr's body was thus plunged into the depths, his soul flew off
to the highest heaven, to sit in the assembly of the first born.
His relics were later found and translated to the vicinity of Antioch, three miles from
the city on the Daphne Road, where a chapel was built in his honor greatly venerated because
of the innumerable healings that took place there, especially of those possessed by demons.
This chapel was burned down during the Persian invasion of 537.
Through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.